[موسيقى]
طريق العمل غير النظام محفوفا بالمخاطر
ليس فقط بالنسبه للعمال بالايضا بالنسبه
لاصحاب الاعمال الذين يتهربون من دفع
مستحقات الموظف للضمان الاجتماعي والسلطات
الضريبيه هذا الفعل يضعهم تحت مسائله
القانونيه في حال كشف امرهم وفي لقائنا مع
ميسر ابو غليون وهو استشاريون عمالي من
الذين يدافعون عن الموظفين في المحاكم
العماريه تعرفنا على نص القانون وما يترتب
على كل الطرفين
جدا
تعتبر انه المال العام اللي هي ضرائب
مقدسه لذلك المشرع
سجن ثلاث سنوات زائد مخالفه 45 الف يورو
عن كل عامل يعني
غير مصرح
والعقوبه يعني تقريبا بدوبل للخمس سنوات
سجن مع 75000 يورو مخالفه اذا وجدوا عامل
تحت 18 سنه
وحتى تذهب العقوبه الى التجاره للبشر
بالنسبه للمهاجرين غير الشرعيه الذين لا
يملكون اوراق في فرنسا وبالنسبه للاجئين
ما هي
العواقبره
المحققين الذين يذهبون هدوم المحققين
ضرائب ليس دورهم تسليم هذا الرجل شرطه
فانت اذا مقيم وعم تشتغل بالاسود هو
المشكله عندك
يعني بدك تعوض مركز المساعدات الدولي كل
شيء
والضرائب ستقوم بمراجعه حساباتك 3 سنوات
الى الوراء
وتعوضهم وتستطيع المساعدات الاجتماعيه
ان ترفع دعوه ضدك امام المحاكم وفيها
سنتين سجن مع 375 الف يورو مخالفه
اموال الدوليه